topspiel am freitagabend dortmund auf
zwei empfängt die viertplatzierten
freiburger der bvb will den schwung aus
der dramatischen schlussphase gegen
frankfurt mitnehmen und tut das auch
tormann je nach brand eckball zum ersten
in der 14 und zum zweiten gehen der 29
spielminute doppelpack vom belgier der
in dieser saison zuvor noch gar nichts
getroffen hat noch vor der pause stellte
er in holland auf drei zu null und
umgeht damit einen persönlichen
negativrekord nachdem er in den letzten
beiden spielen nicht getroffen hatte
zwar kommt der sportclub durch demir
olic in der 61 minute noch mal ran der
hier einen abpraller vontobel verwerten
kann doch bauland nach der buchvorlage
in der 75 legt noch mal nachts um 4 zu 1
den schlusspunkt setzt dann selbst in
der 86 minute fünf zu eins gewinnt der
bvb im top spiel und macht den bayern
damit richtig druck
[Applaus]
aber mit druck kennen sie sich aus die
münchner auch wenn mit steffen baumgart
kölnern durchaus eine harte nuss auf den
tabellenführer wartet aber dafür haben
die bayern ja ihm robert lewandowski der
bayerische nussknacker in der neunten
spielminute zum 1 0 vermeintlich im
abseits der video assistent aber stellt
zu recht fest treffer ist regulär auch
in der folge haben die gäste die partie
im griff und erhöhen durch tolle so
sehenswert in der 25 minute zum 2 0 köln
gelingt weiterhin nicht viel und so darf
nach sany vorarbeit lewandowski den
doppelpack schnüren drei zu null nach 62
minuten
und auch den schlusspunkt markierte
robert lewandowski wieder ist seine der
assistent 74 minute vier zu null der
boje markiert seinen dritten treffer im
spiel und seinen drei hundertsten
insgesamt in der bundesliga das ist vor
ihm nur gerd müller gelungen drei punkte
also für den fcb dem druck damit stand
gehalten
vom meisterschaftskampf in den um europa
nur drei punkte liegen zwischen union
auf 7 und der drittplatzierten tsg und
den gästen gehört auch die anfangsphase
wenngleich sie beim führungstreffer auf
baumgartens mithilfe angewiesen sind
[Applaus]
zuvor lässt bebo knoche altaussee null
zu eins nach 16 minuten
berlin aber beweist charakter nur sechs
minuten später köpft vogel sommer den
ball an die latte von dort springt der
baumann an die schulter und anschließend
ins tor pech also auch auf der anderen
seite eins zu eins in der folge bestimmt
hoffenheim das geschehen kann die
führung aber nicht wiederherstellen die
übernimmt dafür union 73 minute kruse an
den querbalken prömel staubt wie schon
beim 2 2 gegen leverkusen ab 21 spiel
gedreht damit gewinnt union erstmals in
der bundesliga zu hause gegen hoffenheim
nutznießer der tsg niederlage könnte
leverkusen im nebel von gladbach sein
nach einer highlight armen ersten hälfte
pariert ja im sommer den strafstoß von
patrick schick in der 50 spielminute
nach der darauffolgenden ecke muss der
schweizer aber dennoch hinter sich
greifen weil robert an sich hier völlig
unbedrängt aus kurzer distanz zum 1 0
einschieben darf danach bayer der chef
im ring 74 minute die freistoßflanke von
demir bei verlängere patrick schick ins
tor zum 2 0 bereits sein achter treffer
im 16 spiel leverkusen verpasst es dann
den sack zuzumachen und so kommt
gladbach noch mal ran lw die fälscher
spielgerät nach dem eckball vor die füße
21 81 minute
drei minuten vor schluss gibt es dann
nochmal strafstoß aber auch den versuch
von dem ihr bei ihren sommer parieren
doch trotz starker leistung ihres
schlussmannes verlieren die fohlen mit 1
noch immer wartet leipzig in dieser
saison auf einen auswärtssieg unter t
disco soll es nun beim vfb stuttgart
klappen der weg dafür wird schon in der
elften minute geebnet weil andré schäfer
einen von avalos verschuldeten elfmeter
souverän verwandelt im weiteren verlauf
ist es peter gola che zu verdanken dass
die leipziger führung bestehen bleibt
immer wieder entschärft der ungar
hochkaräter wie hier von angela in der
63 minute der treffer aber fällt auf der
anderen seite henrichs schickten kongo
und der franzose bestätigt einmal mehr
seine überragende form 20 in der siebten
spielminute erst wird ito verladen dann
eiskalt abgeschlossen rb kann also auch
auf fremden platz noch gewinnen
um big points gegen mainz 05 auf 10
empfangen aufsteiger bohrung auf platz
11 die gäste minute 32 mit der grossen
chance zur führung aber polter scheitert
mit einem schwachen versuch am zentner
doppelt bitter für folter eigentlich
wollte pantelic den schießen harry
potter setzte sich durch ein tor zur
pause dafür dann aber kurze wartezeit im
zweiten durchgang burkhardt für sanchez
1 0 1 guter abschluss von sanchez der
nach dreimonatiger verletzungspause
heute wieder in der startelf stand zum
glück für svensson und co denn auch nach
90 umkämpften minuten heisst es 1 0 für
den fsv
[Musik]
wolfsburg mit mittlerweile acht
pflichtspiel-niederlagen in folge für
die wölfe soll gegen die hertha
unbedingt mal wieder ein erfolgserlebnis
her dass sie zu beginn auch ganz gut aus
aber sowohl waldschmidt in der 16 als
auch welch horst zwei minuten später
scheitern mit ihren versuchen
kurz vor der pause jubeln dann die gäste
der treffer von stark aber wird nicht
anerkannt weil ecken kampf fusion hier
leicht geschoben hat harte entscheidung
glück für den vfl zu tun kommt es hier
nicht immerhin nach ableiten gibt es
zumindest mal wieder ein pünktchen für
kuwait und seine wölfe
startelf premiere für augsburgs
rekordtransfer gegen frankfurt afrikaner
baby zeigen was er kann zunächst zeigen
aber die gäste was sie können weildorf
sie mit dem fehlpass einlädt und dann
geht schnell über links trimborn und
kanada eins zu null nach 22 minuten
tolle bewegung vom japaner
augsburg ansonsten aber mindestens auf
augenhöhe 38 minute gago mit dem ball
für gregor it ausgleich
da sieht dabei nicht gut aus der den
corona positiven trapp ersetzt
spekuliert auf die hereingabe und macht
deshalb die lücke auf für den
österreicher eins zu eins zwischen
augsburg und frankfurt
zum abschluss des spieltages geht's in
den tabellen keller 17 gegen 18
bielefeld gegen fürth vor allem für die
gäste wäre ein sieg von immenser
bedeutung den besseren start aber
erwischt die arminia das risiko cover 1
0 nach acht minuten danach aber wird
sich bielefeld auf dem treffer aus ein
fehler denn offenbar ist auch nebeling
ausgeruht ist mit ball schneller als an
gerade ohne und bleibt dann auch vor dem
kasten ausgleich 35 minute das momentum
jetzt als auf seiten der gäste und das
vieh genutzt werden the green für den
eingewechselten aber nächsten 7 60
minute 2 1 spiel gedreht den
sehenswerten schlusspunkt setzte gonzalo
castro und der 83 zum 22 eine
punkteteilung die vor allem für twitter
die ergebnisse in der übersicht dortmund
und die bayern überzeugen mit deutlichen
siegen gegen freiburg beziehungsweise
köln leipzig feiert beim 2 0 gegen den
vfb stuttgart seinen ersten auswärtssieg
in dieser saison leverkusen gewinnt das
samstagabend spielt bei gladbach mit 2
zu 1
an der tabellenspitze ändert sich damit
nichts dahinter aber wird spannend
zwischen rang drei der jetzt von
leverkusen belegt wird und den kölnern
auf rang neun liegen gerade einmal vier
punkte ganz ähnlich die situation im
abstiegskampf gladbach auf 12 liegt nur
vier punkte vor stuttgart auf 17 wird
bleibt weiter abgeschlagen letzter
[Musik]